[Music]
this is what happened sorry no blast off
but um i can tell you this story tell me
the story please
tell me today gwyneth paltrow
what about her you know she has her goop
goop
candles her goop blog slash store
magazine if i didn't know that it kind
of slightly sounds like
an insult like a slang yeah like oh it's
a goop like a racial slur
shut up you goop yeah i think not korean
oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ] yeah that's
also a movie
i think of super goop group super group
oh yeah
yeah for me i think of uh like i don't
know why
and this is gross but i think of
discharge oh like pus
or like semen like it just like goop but
like it's coming out like
oh just discharge in general otherwise
you would have said semen
i understand yeah i don't think of semen
as a discharge
yeah i wouldn't think of stephen as just
trying to like it's like yeah joe
spegma is discharged
that was a new thing i don't get that no
more because i clean it charge what
you've got in it oh you said that i just
got chilled all over my mind talking
about dick cheese or discharge
oh no no no dick cheese i don't talk
about gwen patrol okay we are
going to salsa she got dick cheese no
she doesn't but like i said
uh goop right so in her latest
blog post her latest and greatest she
explained how her family
is like coping with quarantine and you
know just
blog stuff and so she just so happened
to mention
that she purchased a interesting puzzle
for her 14 year old son it's a zebra
okay so this is going to falter and her
son
mm-hmm and she purchased wow he looks
like grandma
his boobies puzzles
that's pretty cool that's funny that's
pretty cool
all these different things so funny
different shapes and sizes
[Music]
those boobies are so bad i can't even
jack off to it
some of them are nice you don't like the
artistic style i like some of them no i
think it's for jokes yeah
yeah that's all the kind of boobies you
make when you're a kid and you just drop
them real quick they just look like
eyeballs because they're like within
what about them though what do you mean
this so she purchased this puzzle for
her 14 year old son
and so people are like that's
inappropriate and so he
was having a boner the whole time i
don't know seriously
he just didn't know what he was building
i think that's funny
it's not even sexualized i mean whatever
you want to think was just like why
you could have gotten like a castle or
something maybe date anything else like
why that but it's funny it's not a joke
like i don't know
yeah she doesn't seem like the joking
type well she obviously
wanted something because she took a
candle name this smells like my orgasm
so i don't know vagina right no and a
vagina no another one's
orgasm oh so she is very like this i
guess
oh that's funny yeah cause i don't know
her but if i were gonna buy some
like thing like that for my daughter or
my son or whatever
it's a joke and i would buy something
like that like i would buy that for
anybody it's a little bit weird though
like as a mom getting your 14 year old
son
it's a little bit weird right well what
if it was a what if it was all dicks
so let's say if i was like a dad to my
14 year old daughter getting this but
penises
yeah that's funny that's weird i think
it depends on the relationship
that's way weird it depends on
relationship if you have a goofy
light-hearted relationship i think
anything's cool
i mean yeah i don't know it depends to
me it depends if it's sexualized or not
that's
what makes it weird is for example like
this is cartoon boobies right
it's not hot erotic boobies so if it was
a puzzle
of a bunch of porn stars if you're 14
wouldn't you find this hot and erotic
no that's what i'm saying you've already
been watching porno for two years
i don't think so yeah three years boobs
i mean obviously like i like boobs but i
don't think they should be as sexualized
as like a penis or a vagina right that
should be covered up but if a girl wants
to show her to chore tits
like we show our chest or everything so
i only said penis because of the
variation possibilities
from an artistic there's variations in
vaginas yeah
yeah a lot of areas yeah sure but i
think that that would be
drawing a bunch of vaginas i think is
actually weirder than drawing a bunch of
penises
well i mean there's only differences in
penises and shape and then curve and
maybe a circumcised and that's
pretty much it there's the paintiness
and the bowl there's a lot of
variety hair you can do that with uh
vaginas circumcised or not
yeah i don't know man i just think body
parts are funny
like feet can be funny like look at that
guy's feet oh that guy speaks big
or like look at that dick that's a funny
dick yeah i just want to know her
thought process of why would she give
that yeah so what does this have to do
with goop
she just she obviously knows what she's
doing with that in the blog post all she
wrote was
just for fun that's the reason [ __ ] it
it's her kid
yeah whatever i mean she's iron man's
wife so she would do whatever she wants
[ __ ] uptight dude it was a movie like
maybe she knows that her son loves
titties so she's like i'm gonna give her
something about it right if you're with
your family right and then you know in
thailand like
they have those booths like they have
those street markets night markets or
whatever
um they'll have like wood carving booths
and then they'll be like
happy dicks oh yeah like like penis ball
openers and stuff
yeah it's [ __ ] bad it's hilarious and
then if you see that with your family
wouldn't you laugh with your family i
don't know who
if you guys have like super conservative
family or not but if my parents saw that
they would have been like hey look at
this
that dick has a happy face and i'll be
like yeah that's [ __ ] hilarious i
would laugh with my parents but if my
mom
bought one for me isn't that funny i
i don't know if i like what if she
bought a [ __ ]
laughing dick statue because she got it
in like japan or thailand or whatever
and then she comes home and then she
gives it to you she's like look at what
i found you're gonna love this [ __ ]
i did get that from my mother-in-law it
was really cute
like she gave me like this tiny little
thing it was like a little like a
kangaroo patch it was in kangaroo patch
it was like a little figurine but like
made out of clay
that you're supposed to add water or
something but it had like a little penis
attached to it
and she was like oh this is funny and
then i was just like yeah that's funny
yeah but then was it molesty well
because she's my mother-in-law
married to her son like there's a
different relationship if i got this
from like my stepdad
it'd be kind of weird did you know
there's a camera in there she's been
spying on you
she can't see [ __ ] because it's in the
drawer i could imagine this being
potentially
a an interesting parenting lesson if
like let's say her son
like had a misconception about the
sexualization of boobs or something like
that or like maybe
was questioning like why are you not
wearing it that's so weird that you can
see your nipples and
there's like a desensitizing lesson
process that's exactly what i thought
when i put myself in her shoe in gwyneth
paltrow's shoes and because i have a 12
year old so i'm like would i give this
to isaac
um i don't know if i would but i don't
know if i'm like hard against or hard
for
like i'm just kind of like if what if
the kid was gay and so she bought it
from him and the kid's like
she thinks that's funny you know what i
mean
no because he doesn't like boobies if he
was gay oh
so she okay it's a test yeah yeah yeah
it's like me getting a [ __ ]
a giant mural full of dicks i'm like god
damn it dad you know i don't like dicks
that's funny oh
and then and then so yeah so what you're
saying is that she had the dick puzzle
behind her back and i was waiting to see
if he was gonna be down with this one or
not right right right
or she might even know that like what
because the real prank would be if she
had a dick puzzle and she gave it to him
and he's like
ugh right yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense okay
but but yeah i think i would i would
give it to isaac
base if if it was with the process
of like desensitizing him and like not
sexualizing it so heavily and being like
here
like it's a woman's body like chill but
isn't it
don't you desexualize it when you can
laugh about it
and you don't make it so hidden and
taboo with your family
which is probably why she posted on her
blog make it super untapped right so for
people who are against it aren't they
perpetuating the whole uh weird
sexualization of women bodies parts
yeah probably you should like because
for me i'm not against it it's just i'm
just like
a little weirded out not weirded out i
just want a little purpose behind why
right compared to something else right
um but on sale maybe
maybe what if it wasn't that anthony
said what if it was for that reason that
happened
on sale to like desensitize like a
lesson
which is great because i feel like in in
society we should go away from trying to
like
be like oh the girls have to be covered
up like this and like it's a shame
because
guys can't control themselves and guys
are stupid um and that's like from like
the whole muslim side of it like why
when girls cover themselves up
um that wasn't like the the whole
thought process back then it was
supposed to be like
guys can't control themselves so we're
supposed to turn our own head away
uh and then they kind of interpret that
their own way i heard two back then
like if you had a hot wife some guys
would come up
and just kill you and then like
take your wife damn whoa yeah when
oh from muslim not muslim but like just
humanity humans yeah because that sounds
like some mongolian [ __ ]
yeah yeah so then like it was to protect
the women if they all had the burqas or
whatever also
it was kind of like to protect that's
what i heard
just history wise just weird
ways to i don't but that's normal though
back then like
people coming into your village and just
straight up jacking the girls or
whatever that was normal and then like
even
even now they have this weird tradition
where like wive kidnapping is a normal
thing
oh i saw that you know like some
some cultures still keep it like what
you know okay so
and i think it's kazakhstan and then
yeah and i know that
mongs i don't know if they did it or do
it now but they did it
uh uh there's and then there's some
cultures where
in order to there's a vice dock on it in
order to marry someone you have to
kidnap them
it's a part of the tradition so like and
it could happen where you just kidnap a
girl off a street and then she comes
into your house or it's more like you
guys been dating for a while and instead
of like
proposing you kidnap them with your
friends and their parents are cool
stays at your house for 24 hours
that's when the wedding ceremony starts
like that's the engagement that's
everything they don't date
no they can date so like let's say
you're dating somebody
but instead of being engaged to like
like will you marry me or whatever
they roll up in the van with their
friends they kidnap you
they take you home and then you stay at
the
uh the bride stays at the groom's house
for 24 hours and then they tell the
parents and then
from there they prepare for the ceremony
and then they have like a week-long
party
the whole time the girl's like screaming
and crying though what if you're like
dating her
and then i just come and steal her i
don't know if that's a part of it but
i'm saying in ancient times
that was very true oh in ancient times
that's a part of it for sure yeah
wow it could i'm thinking that some
people some people are saying that
it's it could be a result of protecting
women
where like if all of them were masked up
then you don't know who's pretty and
who's not because then the guys would
fight over the pretty girls
yeah they just like with this concept
they just like mask up but everybody
just shows their boobs
just to desensitize it but to like not
let people focus on how hot you are
funny but then people will fight over
the boob because like isn't back in the
day like people are looking for ankle
and they're just like that's a [ __ ]
ankle right there that's a [ __ ]
ankle right i think that's all just the
joke of it hey but this thing the boob
thing
those had like more realistic boobs yeah
yeah like sag boobs there was only one
that was like
fake tits like two purple because it was
two circles that were separated like
this far apart
you mean this guy right that one
or this one too no that's just improper
size
but round yeah i could not jack off to
that as a kid they
they even have like breast cancer
survivors see that's such an educational
like oh i thought those are chinese eyes
this person needs to get some sleep
dark circles yeah i like how some of
them are perfect we're just idiots when
they're like all eyeballs
[Music]
so